i'm tasked with an exceedingly difficult
[Music]
task
in disclosing the manner of
of
the way my mother chose
not to continue to live
i will share with you that she used a
weapon
mother used a firearm ashley judd in
tears revealing her mother naomi's cause
of death mother used a firearm
so that's the piece of information that
we
are very uncomfortable sharing but
understand that we're in a position that
you know if we don't say it someone else
is going to
it's ashley's first interview since
naomi died on april 30th at the age of
76 which we know now was a result of a
self-inflicted gunshot wound in an
emotional pre-taped interview with abc
news's diane sawyer ashley opens up
about her mom's battle with mental
illness my mother knew
that she was seen and she was hurt and
her anguish
and that
[Music]
that she
she
she was walked home
when we're talking about mental illness
it's very important and
to be clear and to make the distinction
between our loved one and the disease
it's very real
and it's an it is it is enough to
it
it lies
it's savage ashley then goes into detail
about naomi's final day i was at the
house visiting as i
am every day
and mom said to me will you stay with me
and i said of course i will
ashley went outside to bring in a
comforting person who had arrived when
she came back i went upstairs to let her
know that the friend was there and i
discovered her i have both grief and
trauma
from
um from discovering her my mother
our mother
couldn't hang on
until she was inducted into the hall of
fame
by her peers as she's referring to the
country music hall of fame naomi died
the night before she and her daughter
wynonna who make up the country duo the
judds were slated to be inducted at the
ceremony ashley and wynonna put on brave
faces to accept the honor and pay
tribute to their late mother
my mama loved you so much
and she appreciated your love for her
and i'm sorry that she couldn't hang on
until today
um
i'm going to make this fast because my
heart's broken
and
i feel so blessed and it's a very
strange dynamic
to be this broken in this blast
i mean that is the level of catastrophe
of what was going on
inside of her because
the
the barrier between
the regard in which they held her
couldn't penetrate
into her heart
and the lie that the disease told her
was so convincing but at the end of the
day ashley wants people to remember
naomi for her big heart she was
a brilliant conversationalist she was a
star she was an underrated songwriter
and she was someone who suffered from
mental illness you know and had a lot of
trouble getting off the sofa
except to go into town every day to the
cheesecake factory where all the staff
knew and loved her that's the way she
was and she always had 100 bills stuffed
in her bra and she was passing them out
to the janitorial staff
you know just an unfailingly
kind
sensitive
woman and one thinks for sure naomi had
so much love for her two daughters
in the early 90s the country music
legend opened up to e.t about the close
bond with her daughters which only grew
stronger as the years went on boy you
get the three of us together and we are
just
we're like three high spirited horses we
just have this exponential strength
to us
it's phenomenal the three i tell tell
the girls that the triangle you know is
the strongest structure
and i think because we've been through
everything together
the joys and the triumphs and
it's what i try to tell people that in
our struggles triumphs and tragedies
you get the glimpse of your own
[Music]